you should do some research on the
braces and figure out how we could pop
some diamonds in here yeah there's some
stones in there
yeah what's up gq i'm coyla ray and
you're watching on the rocks
[Music]
let's bring the best jeweler here yo joe
aviati get in here let's talk about this
jewelry
i met joe
i think i had shot my video there at
your store we released the watch for a
puffy son you had made a comment on his
post and i and i reached out to you and
then you came in the next day and we sat
there and we we thought about it and i
just i analyzed you and i and i looked
at your personality i looked at your
tattoos i saw you you really are into
butterflies this was the first piece
that we worked on she loves butterflies
and she also has like fire flames on on
the arm as well with the butterflies so
on this particular piece right here we
ended up putting together a butterfly
that's basically on fire a butterfly is
like a beautiful thing and then you also
have like the fire crazy life side of me
the crazy side so you got the butterfly
flying over the fire when i explained
that to him he brought it to life with
my favorite piece in her collection this
particular piece right here let me tell
you something this right here yo i walk
in the studio i could be with the
biggest rapper rapper the rapper rapper
they'll see my watch and be like yo
this the hottest thing i've ever seen
like i feel like i even topped the guys
with the watches ain't no rolly ate
nobody messing with this watch right
here she originally bought the watch as
a a bus down jubilee band i wanted to
play in james but he's like no you're a
rapper now you're an artist so you need
to turn up i don't trust anybody but i
trusted him look you gotta have
something that's like eye-catching all
her pieces if you look at it they're not
just jewelry everything is a piece of
art i know everything has something
that's a representation of her i can't
have the same thing as no one else i
love my watch it's just a statement
piece like i make sure my watch is on my
hand when i'm holding the mic so they
can see it when i'm performing these two
pieces are my only playing pieces
because that's what i want to like put
on a little bodysuit some flip-flops and
i'm on the island and when i'm outside
i'm going to the club i'm putting on my
chain and i guarantee you i'm catching
all eyes also too this is one of my
favorite pieces dee had got this for my
birthday and this actually glows in the
dark so in the club like you see this
glowing stars around my neck which i
think is so fire it's like laser tag
baby like pull up let's turn up
[Music]
since we on this segment you know i
still haven't heard anything about this
from you like i love this chain we
worked on this together this is a
collaboration right here and one of my
inspirations behind this was pharrell's
chain he posted this it's like a gold
link chain yeah but it had these all the
gemstones gems and i was like yo i want
different colored gems but i don't want
to just take parrell idea i got to set
the trend and do something bigger we
have to sit there and come up with this
locking mechanism and she don't like the
word mechanism the lock mechanism i hate
the word mechanism because of you now
oh my god mechanism i think this is
watch we don't like it it took us about
two months to try to figure out how we
can connect it without having to tamper
with the medallion at all i ain't never
seen another julie do that i'm not just
saying that because we're family but
like i swear everything else is just
generic
how much did the
koi chain cost something like that is it
easily in the ballpark
give me the total
right here you got a good 400 000 oh
400k on my neck don't tell me that i'm
going to make my album release like 400k
on my body
i always wear my koi piece if i'm
performing it's lit i'm like do your
chain hang low and then if i want to
take it off
i just take these two apart i don't have
to wear this big piece
and now it's like i could have the sun
in the moon or i could just make it a
link change make this the lock put it in
the back and now we just got link koi
links first one in the world with koi
fish
links like are you kidding me this ring
right here that's that right there
it's right there
it's a cross so i can't say [ __ ] you
would cross my head but i've done it in
god for gives you understand sorry guys
sometimes you gotta just
but yeah
imagine sometimes i'm like [ __ ] you with
this ice on your hand like it's the best
feeling in the world you know what i'm
saying it's a certain way i guess you
have to wear like i don't know if i wear
it this way or if i wear it this way i
know but they want us to be able to see
it you know what i mean so do i i want
to see it that's like when i get my
nails done you think i'm going to get
the character facing you no
character facing me
we're doing trendsetter chains and we're
the chinsetter chain has
enamel behind the name just to bring it
out i love animal work i feel like it's
gonna get more popular too after this i
don't know men pride and eagles would be
a little weird i guess in this industry
like it needs to be diamonds all
diamonds all diamonds but as a creator
like you see them iced out in all
different aspects this right here is a
whole body chain and when you put it on
it sits on my stomach and it has an ammo
and i think it's so sexy and it's so
cute i embrace my body i love body
positivity we're working on our body
chain collection we're gonna have
butterflies we're gonna have stars we're
gonna have the aviani logo in the back
cause i feel like my fans are gonna die
to see that loyalty is everything i've
been working with joe since i've started
when you build a relationship with
someone it becomes more than just me
buying jewelry that's why i love working
with you you know that when i sit there
and i talk to you it's not like talking
to a wall that's why i think we work
great together we actually have so many
more things coming not only for me but
for my fans thanks for checking out my
jewelry i hope you guys loved it go
check out my album big trendsetter and
i'm checking out see ya